diese Frau Rosalind Franklin hat einen
großen Beitrag zur Entschlüsselung der
dnastruktur geleistet aber nie die
Credits dafür bekommen vor 70 Jahren
wurde dieses paper über die DNA
veröffentlicht die beiden
Wissenschaftler dahinter Watson h und
Crick waren an der Uni Cambridge tätig
Franklin arbeitete am Kings College ihr
Kollege Wilkins zeigte Watson und Crick
das Photo 51 das von ihr und einem
Doktoranten am Kings College aufgenommen
wurde etwas später erhielten sie
außerdem Daten die Franklin gesammelt
hatte ohne sie zu erwähnen oder sie um
Erlaubnis zu fragen haben Francis und
Crick die Daten interpretiert wenige
Wochen später wurden die Ergebnisse in
der Zeitschrift Nature publiziert das
Modell von Watson und Crick die anderen
Daten von Wilkins und Franklin 1958
starb Franklin an Eierstockkrebs
vielleicht sogar verursacht durch die
rönkgenstrahlung mit der sie gearbeitet
hatte und vier Jahre später wurde der
Nobelpreis für die Entdeckung an Watson
und Crick vergeben die beide den Impuls
von Rosalind Franklin mit keinem Wort
erwähnten deswegen noch mal